the leaders of deadly anti Israeli
protests in Gaza say today is a day for
funerals there were new demonstrations
in the West Bank after yesterday's
repeated clashes along Israel's border
the White House blamed Hamas the radical
group that runs Gaza for the deadliest
day of violence in nearly four years the
United Nations condemned the appalling
deadly violence Holly Williams attended
one of this morning's funerals in Gaza
Holly good morning good morning they
have just buried two Palestinian men who
were killed at yesterday's protest here
at martyrs Cemetery in the Gaza Strip
the death toll according to officials
here is now more than 60 and that is a
stunning loss of life for many
Palestinians they carried their dead
to be buried here in Gaza including
several children caught up in the
bloodshed more than 1300 people are
alive but suffered gunshot wounds
according to Palestinian officials most
of the dead were killed along the border
fence that separates the tiny
poverty-stricken gaza strip from Israel
where tens of thousands of Palestinians
held angry demonstrations yesterday
furious after the US Embassy was moved
to Jerusalem Israel responded with
deadly force live ammunition aimed at
those it says got too close to the fence
the Palestinians hope East Jerusalem
will one day be their capital if they
ever get their own state and they are
furious over what they say is American
bias towards Israel again it's the door
the President Trump how come Abu shanab
is a financial analyst and was one of
the protesters are you willing to die
here we don't have any other method that
we could use instead of you know dying
is the only way the Israeli military
says it also launched airstrikes
yesterday targeting a camp run by Hamas
the militant group that controls the
Gaza Strip and Israeli media is
reporting that Israel has threatened to
assassinate Hamas leaders if the violent
protests continue there were more
protests planned for today to mark the
70th anniversary of what Palestinians
call their day of catastrophe following
the founding of the State of Israel
but so far very few demonstrators have
gone to the border fence today
Gail Holly Williams reporting from Gaza
thank you very much